we're gonna do this um inductively kind
of right so we're just gonna build from
simple things and build up to build up
to this guy vertex form okay
so let's consider something that we know
and we'll go from there so I'm gonna
give you how many I got one two three
four
like six or seven different equations
the files and we're just gonna
investigate the different operators okay
so the standard vanilla parabola is y
equals x squared and has a vertex
where's its vertex it's at the origin
right the vertex is at zero zero no big
deal okay
now the most familiar way we have of
shifting this thing is left and right
because it's in a factorized form
already in a sense right so here's
another different version if I just say
X minus one Oscar and give it to you a
nice dress okay its vertex has shifted
over right what direction is a moved is
right it's moved to the right okay you
can quickly see like x equals one is the
route that the that's where the vertex
is right so I've got the vertex at one
zero okay if I take away something I go
to the right that it stays to reason if
I add something again to modify which
way am I going now I'm going to the left
right where's the vertex this time okay
so it's negative two and I haven't gone
anywhere vertically so so far so good
okay now let's take this X plus two more
squared died right now if I like you in
this form X plus 2 or square that might
add three to this right-hand side if I
add three then it stands to reason that
my vertex which used to be here is going
to go up right so the vertex is now
going to be negative two
that's the number I meant to say now I
want to clarify what's going on here
though just like I did sort of over here
right which is that plus three right the
plus three the three is really modifying
the Y it's a vertical thing all right so
to clarify that I'm going to do this you
see that okay so I can read off the
vertex of this view they are two three
by looking at these numbers negative two
because that's the X that's the one who
comes first I've flipped it around okay
with that yes that's exactly right
almost all I'm not my fugitive yeah
that's exactly right there's different
ones okay so let's think about this a
little generally right I read this off
by reading these numbers in Reverse as
it were right so if I want to generalize
and go in the other direction by saying
what if I have vertex and just by
convention I honestly am not entirely
sure why they do this but anyway they
choose these letters for the coordinates
of the vertex right
who knows maybe maybe there was some
real classy honky mathematician who was
just can't keep digging dogs
okay what I'm gonna say is right here is
here is an original problem that's right
I've moved it to the right H units I've
moved it upwards
Kate units right I can't by the way I
can tell you why it's not fine that's
cuz I stands for something else
important okay so that's why I've
skipped over and I've got the lye pot
it's moved upwards K units so this
should be why - can you see that okay
and exactly the same way I've got X - H
why don't we keep it over here well I
think clarity there is put this I think
it's debatable I see your point I agree
I mean when I when I learned this for
the first time I think this looks a lot
more obvious that it's like an plus
means going up right the problem with
that approach is that it doesn't bear
out doing these things right like
there's no way to escape the factorized
form of X plus whatever Square and it
takes you if it's a plus it takes you
that way so you have to come to terms
with things going backwards the way you
think they are by the way there's no way
to avoid that and so the thing that I
think people will like about this
mathematicians anyway is they see that's
more to find the X and that's what a
find a y so that's why there's a
horizontal is a vertical so there's a
symmetry of that form which you miss if
you write it like this
all right now there's my vertex at HK
right if I wanted any parabola that had
that vertex because there's a whole
bunch right for example that's x squared
plus one that's this 51 so if I put and
you can actually maybe draw this
alongside with me right if I have a
parabola and its vertex is H K right
there okay there's a infinite number of
parabolas that all share that vertex
right for example if you went if he went
upside down if you flipped upside down
like so
say vertex right well what I do to that
by the way how would I fit that upside
down I would want to modify where would
I put the minus sign okay
I'm just gonna pause there that is such
a good question there's a variety of
places you can put the negative sign
here I will let you have a think about
where you think it might go and why
don't why not I'll give you in it from
get Sara I'll give you an answer by the
implicit hey but it's not hard to
empirically yes yes so there's more than
one place to put it but I'd just like to
suggest if there's a better place and a
poor place to put no no no no so I can I
can add or subtract anything I like in
here right and it will not have any
impact on where it's going vertically it
will only have any impact on where it's
going I'd like you to compare these two
you compare them you have a think about
it you go away and think about it and
think about the difference between them
and what difference vertically there is
I'll just leave that question with you
now I've got these two they share this
vertex but I'm missing infinitely many
right where else kind of put yeah I
could just make this thing like steeper
right or I could make it so I could get
sideways but in order to do that I'd
have to do something little more
fundamental I would have to switch my
X's and Y's but if I want something to
be orient in a different direction I'd
have to do that okay
but all of these guys still have
this form with one difference he's my
last one why this shares the same vertex
it shares the same vertex but that
factor of a just like this factor of a
is changing what is happening in terms
of squashing or squeezed even making it
you know thin or fat okay so this
equation here is not just a parabola is
every parabola whose vertex is H K does
that make sense
no no it's correct it's just where a is
equal to one that's just a specific just
like all of these are specific problem
this is a specific one too but this one
is a whole set of them depending on and
I guess you could put this over here
depending on your value okay okay
alright so that's vertex form now just
really quickly right how do you get to
vertex form well this morning we were
looking at the general form and the way
we got out the quadratic formula was we
what do we do to it we made extra
subject we completed the square to make
X the subject right I want to pull you
back to this example that we did okay
now you could probably you could
probably have a look at your working
this morning and see the panel but let's
just do it again for the sake of it and
you can see the logic we won't even have
to go as far as we did this morning okay
what's the first thing I can do remember
this is in general on the right hand
side what's the feature that's really
obvious in general form there's only one
so y-intercept right so to make that
obvious
I'm gonna kick everything up you see
that okay it's a bit mean but anyhow
here we find he'll survive numbers a
resilient so I've got my Y minus 6 so
I'm trying to get toward this right you
see that hey what have I got to get over
here I need a square tonight you see
I've got a perfect square
yeah which is why completing the square
is important now you remember you
remember the number that we added didn't
we you have and then you square your
Harvey as well so it's it's 25 on 4
which is six and a quarter Evelyn
so we add that to both sides okay now
I'll go left hand side excuse me
that's pretty simple you can just crunch
through like so deal with that and on
the right hand side I have my square
that I wanted right this is X plus was
it two and a half right yeah okay I know
we went further this morning because we
wanted a solution for X right but if all
I want is the vertex I have it do you
see there's my x coordinate of my vertex
it's negative tuna huh and there's my y
coordinate of my projects its negative
1/4 which is not surprising because
negative 1/2 negative 3 if that's where
your two roots are right because my
turrets are so very close together
there's no opportunity being but it's
Wanek right there's no opportunity for
it to drop very far it's only got this
tiny little space right and by the time
it gets halfway across because it's
symmetrical it has this one around okay
so you've got negative 2 there negative
3 there and negative 2 and are right in
between right and negative 1/4 is how
far you've dropped down not very far but
that's because it's small okay